um what's been your biggest interview so  far views wise  yeah uh the biggest episode i did was  tucker i think that was sitting at  almost it's headed to 3 million that  [ __ ]  she  was  crazy  [ __ ] clustered [ __ ] bro  because that was like two or three right  that was like quit that was like one of  the first few yeah that was i want to  say  yeah that was some of the first that was  some of the few i just remember like it  was like viral and like my boy's like yo  this dude from phoenix got roasted  i watched that [ __ ] i was like oh man  he's cool ain't nothing against him i  just he didn't know me hey and he turned  it into a bag i think he was selling  like toe sucker shirts or hats or  something [ __ ] something yeah i don't as  you should right [ __ ] it do your thing  do what you got to do bro i'm not here  to stop you not here to hate on you